what does that I could do with my knee
Robert Byrd who used the n-word in 2001
several times if a plane went down with
Obama Biden Clinton Pelosi Robert Byrd
would have been your president he
practically had KKK Dental and a company
car he was as a racist as it came what
does that have to do with me and no one
circumstance can cover everybody's just
like I can only speak for me
I think people a race of people that has
flavor flavor Barack Obama and so it's
rare that I get a lot of guests who I
actually grew up watching as a kid so
right off the bat he had a sitcom that I
watched loved it as a child up there in
Canada we didn't get a lot of
entertainment at least syndicated show a
new program I think on television
Heartbreakers I want to make sure I get
this right comedy tour across the
country DL Hughley thanks so much for
being on the show man I am doing okay
now I'm I'm honestly very appreciative
that you've come on the show because we
probably wouldn't agree on a whole lot
it does but I will say you know it seems
like we're in an era where that's not
really allowed and you don't see a lot
of people going on sort of I guess
competing programs now I do want to just
sort of lay the stage here really
quickly what caught my eye and I felt
sympathetic because I saw you face the
wrath of the Twitter social justice
warriors Larry people think they have a
keyboard and 140 characters that can
alter my opinion I mean I'm sure it's
generally the public is also by that but
I didn't necessarily feel I get it
there's a tip was to make me feel that
generated or to make me feel any level
of backlash I can't say that did well
okay well before we get into that
because I want to get into what exactly
people have been doing with you or if
they have been trying to intimidate you
so this all was spawned from some
comments you may
about Caitlyn Jenner right right I was I
was in Newark I was you know a data geek
so we're doing some promotion so I'm you
know I played to New York so I'm walking
down the street
DMV as they often do I think I saw in
the meantime asked me my opinion of
Caitlyn Jenner and I put in ESP and I
said that you know author ads you know
there was a civil rights civil rights
out there played a segregated board was
segregated the table of segregated
estate and he got age and painting he
was the face of a before that time I'm
aid was you know up Ohio people thought
of the gateleg and they thought it was
God's wrath and he gave us such a human
face that it started to change opinion
and he really died its service of people
Caitlyn Jenner put on the threat so
don't forget the Botox don't forget the
Botox and every driver had I mean listen
I'm not and I think that you know one
person can't be you know you know the
the carry the water for entire move it I
think I want to talk about also hands
into people like I think LeBron
copyright she sprung for the Premium
Pack but just got a day that her own
side it was just hilarious
yeah well Bruce Jenner didn't even get a
sex change he's still got it he still
got the twigs and berries right it's
amazing that you get just a chippy why
you still got a big boy and that's
what's amazing okay like that's
hilarious to me so I think that to me
when it when something like that happens
is you know I've always been able I've
always kind of given my opinion and I
think that it is a shame to me that what
I've agreed with people I'm not like
with Don Imus did we then I through the
same kind of rap but the visitors right
to say to me right is right and wrong is
wrong and if people can't ultimately you
know I'm going to exercise my right to
say what I want and I will choose to be
kind of swayed by whatever public
right well on that note I want to ask
you something because what I noticed and
I want to know if you notice this know
right away the accusations came out
you're a trans folk you know you're an
ANC transgender bigot did you experience
that and do you see that as a way for
people who might disagree with you on a
point to just try and silence the
dialogue before you can even make your
point just oh you're Tran was ridiculous
I've been married to more thirty years
or it I think that people so choose the
simplest narrative and the narrative is
if you have an opposition to somebody
you make a serval about somebody that
you must hate it or fear and neither one
of those through r200 particularly right
well so you face that and I'll tell you
what do you does it give you maybe pause
because I will say this you know glad
you're coming in the program but you
have thrown those insinuations toward
black conservatives or conservatives in
general that they're inherently
prejudiced and I think that what seems
to happen most conservatives black
conservatives tend to be people that
like we're all like in gym and you know
so I think yeah I mean so it's just to
me I'm going to tell you what it is I
think and I think that there is I can't
even think of anybody that by and large
would be respected in both community
that's just true observations are not
respected by that right but my question
is you know as someone who has had a lot
of you know black conservatives on this
program and obvious listen I lean to the
right
I was raised in socialists can and I'm
sure you mean I know you've been to
Montreal I think actually watched your
set at the Just for Laughs as a young
boy so I don't come from this sort of
you know Robert Byrd backwoods KKK
American background but you have made it
I mean you know you did say that
Republicans sort of look like Nazi
Germany or you wouldn't see black lives
matters t-shirts at GOP convention I get
that you're a comedian but you have
levelled that criticism towards
conservatives sometimes in a generality
do you feel like
that's no different than Fox levels
there because there are some people
level their criticisms I don't think
that's any different I think that is
ultimately where some sort of my life's
experiences it when you hear
conservative black conservatives say
like what being cautious David that
Obamacare's worth the slavery what do
you think like it would not think about
that
oh let me let me be specific what do you
think I as a black person anywhere thing
about there yeah but what do you what do
you think what do you think all
conservatives including black or white
sink when you say that Republicans don't
care about black people
here's what I find particularly
confounded I think that you'll find a
number of teachers party conservatives
were very angry and and are concerned
about who are the only ones by the way
the only ones who defended you in the
gener scandal I do want to note that
they well ultimately uh
I think that you see was right
I think the you see was right you
actually got the only people that can
send it defended Filmore when he added
that I think that there is this did and
never the principal argument one I made
on the other in myself so I you know I
think turnabout is fair play I've made
argument so people that have the right
to express themselves I don't think
that's I think it's just an argument
what I will say in terms of whether the
point I was making earlier is you will
have a situation where people are angry
that the government is overstepping
their bounds that they work about
nangbou disturbs the president people's
right but when they see what's happening
in the black people all across the
country they're silent and that to me is
level of inconsistency bit yeah I'm not
seeing that though I'm not I'm not
seeing that and I'm just saying I was
you know in the spirit of respectful
disagreement I've not seen that I've
never heard any Republicans or
conservatives say that they believe that
should be policy I will say I've seen
deafening silence from black liberals
even such as your cell phone you know
the violence in Chicago or the kind of
atmosphere that Barack Obama Chicago is
in dealt with people a black person who
kills a black person is light is going
to jail it's going to jail and they
should go to jail
listen
and when people make that argument to me
black people feel black people 90% of
the time why I didn't kill white people
around 86% of time Latin kill it about
the same ratio so it is not an anomaly
that specifically just people kill the
people that close to no but what is an
anomaly is the number at which black
people kill white people compare the
other side and people have said it in
retort to you accusing them of being
racist that's and you know why people
are arrested on average much more likely
to be arrested young white men than
black people I mean I want the race
thing yeah I have it up on my website
I'll bring it up on the screen right now
my point is this I defended your right
to free speech right and I think you saw
that people were trying to silence you
and I hate that but do you think that
there that you have in the past and I
will say that I do and then I'll give
you the floor have been guilty of doing
that same thing of trying to silence
conservatives kind of like you're doing
now by insinuating racism as concerned
about people you coming into my defense
it's admirable but but my position would
have been my position even alone even
alone let me explain to you why
it does and let me explain to you ideal
and this is this is a big difference
between the left and the right okay I've
never seen the right and I know that
there is no systematic movement from the
right to try and remove someone like you
from the airwaves for your opinion they
try and do that with me on a regular
basis remember when you you you did this
right you tweeted out I defended you
right away
we can pull these up people said really
you're gonna side with a confederate
flag waving racist and I sent you a
column that I wrote condemning the
commander flag no no you didn't you know
but here's a point the same people who
were saying that to you are the same
people who try and silence me to
insinuate that I'm a racist they
insinuate you're a Tran
oh and I'm a racist even even kind of
complete my offending with there is one
almost no I'm not but I'm saying when
you when you say Republicans look like
Nazi Germany I'm arguing it's kind of
similar the Republican Party with the
what are you talking about the entire
party the platform right now where we
have women we have black people we have
Latinos you don't what does that have to
do with the ideas I don't understand I
see and you're playing identity politics
the same things people did with you look
very motherland it look very much like
the Nazi Germany closer and I made a
comment how similar that look that that
still does not change when I when I look
at the picture now coming that's fair I
wasn't saying that you were not being I
said that picture look like it but that
in combination with black lives you
won't see black lives matter t-shirts at
GOP conventions I'm saying okay what
about the fact how about because we
don't want to focus on I first off I'm
not a Republican I'm a conservative I
would never wear a black lives matter
t-shirt because I believe that all lives
matter and I believe it's an issue no no
let me finish let me make a point here
the issue has been conflated for example
when you have cops who are now facing
being offed in record numbers because
you have an administration and pundits
like you you responsibly create a more
racially tense environment I was raised
in a post-racial North America it's
worse than ever because of people
calling people Nazis let's be clear I've
never been one to advocating all you
matter let's be clear but when black
Jesus Lance
here's what I there was an incident
happen to a young guy he a kid named
Tamir right right in in Cleveland he was
playing with a toy gun
he was a cop the cop that killed him was
fired by independence believe
independently farm in Ohio terrible case
I agree with you 100 mount of training
would make him a viable officer he was
hired in Cleveland and the first thing
many on the right deed was entrusted
with finding out that police open a 12
year old boy did the child should never
be responsible it was it was the gun
manufacturers it was the adults in the
room and it was certainly ill training
on the police department what I
constantly see it's constantly is he
conservative even I I would disagree I
would say it's a responsibility of the
officer and he should be punished
ok how could you have not heard that
position even my producer here who's not
a kid who's not a conservative who is a
sort of right-wing question holds that
position okay I'll accept that let's say
that's the that's that's the truth and
no Republicans cared about Tamir rice I
haven't seen that but let's assume that
if that's the I have not seen
Republicans who have defended the cop in
the Tamir rice case but let me no I have
not I have not I have not and this is
what I do now I certainly haven't so let
me speak for myself here if we do that
can we both agree that maybe you need to
apologize to someone like Darren Wilson
for jumping to conclusions on the other
side when he was assaulted I certainly
believe that he's guilty of what he's
charged with
I would never apologize I certainly
believe Darren Wilson murder that boy so
the grand jury testimony no because our
instance it would be as if the Wayans
brothers why the prosecutor the police
officer and the grand jury you know no
no no that's not the case because
including the prosecuting attorneys have
to clear it and you're talking about a
grand jury in that area with many people
who are black so I don't I don't accept
the premise well let me hold on one
second I want it because I want to get
back to where we agree my point is this
it's just a genuine question do you
think this is just a jet because I
really do like you and I think you're
funny and I'm not just saying that
because I know conservatives are going
to get mad
we have a lot of independent
libertarians who listen to the show do
you think though that some of the things
that you have said that have been listen
let's be honest and sometimes it's a
joke so I have more leeway for comedians
insinuating that conservatives or
Republicans are racist generally that
can be designed to silence dialogue just
like the people who said I can't have an
opinion because you're trans folk here's
the thing I appreciate honestly that you
want to defensively but really honestly
if I I would have I say what I say and I
understand I'm we take the conflict and
I certainly most certainly do not
believe it is the equivalent of the
other side is the equivalent of me
telling a joke and I've given an
opposition that observation about Bruce
Jenner or trans trans folk and them
saying oh he's the big you know he's
he's he's anti this is the same thing on
the other side I make jokes that are
from my perspective and some people
don't like them and I understand it I if
I felt bad about them I'd certainly
apologize I don't feel bad about people
misunderstanding of what I said about
Bruce Jenner
Treena and the examples that you've
given me right now I don't feel bad
about those I don't I so I can
understand that Jimmy you're basically
kind of doing what you're accusing other
people's norm is trying to make me feel
a certain way about it you know I didn't
I didn't I didn't I asked a question I
asked a question about and brought up
some examples were you you have leveled
generalizations against conservative you
can't tell me that you can put those
pictures side by side and it doesn't
have a kids of it even though like that
it would use that I can well well then I
think you've been discontinued okay and
I think that most see but see that's the
pivotal difference that's the pivotal
difference mr. Hughley you believe in
ascribing motive you just just I asked
you a question and let let your ideas
stand you told me this is your motive
Stephen you're disingenuous and I don't
believe in arguing that way and that's
what people did to you went to a UH
gave a speech at an event sponsored by
David do right spots about David do and
he got to saying I didn't I wasn't aware
that they were you know separate us or
why or
while our organizational I was unaware
of that and everybody the third most
impossible Republican and and so - so
you it's rife with examples of stuff
like what is money Robert Byrd who used
the n-word in 2001 several times if a
plane went down with Obama Biden Clinton
Pelosi Robert Byrd would have been your
president he practically had KKK dental
and a company car he was as a racist as
it came what does that have to do with
me and no one circumstance can't cover
everybody just like I can only speak for
me I can't speak for a race of people
that has flavor flavor Barack Obama and
so anything I will give you my thing is
in my opinion too many times things like
that specific incident no one said
anything about people that was well
that's ten years ago and so your party
is white good example no no no that's
weird I'm sorry I'm sorry
I believe you're smarter than that I
believe you're smarter than taking a
gracious Republican from 2002 and using
that against me in this debate my point
is tell me what's hilarious you're more
likely to lump them in than I am you
just lump them all into one stack I can
understand you've heard those things and
let's African yet you've heard those
kind of argue well they they I don't I
don't know again you just lumped a whole
bunch of arguments to an entire group of
people and I think a lot of people on
the right they are not comfortable
making those leaps in logic based on and
so to me like the one you just made the
other way suit it is if a young black
man can all be first and always you can
look at a number why they take their
rate I've never I've never heard anyone
say that just like I've never heard yes
yeah it's reality it's reality I've
never we didn't have a secret meeting
behind black people's back people like
me and Alfonso Rachel and Larry elder
who we just had on we did not have a
meeting and say we hate black people but
I did just hear you level some good okay
that's that's fair let me say this and I
do want to find some common ground to
leave it with an olive French because I
appreciate you very much and listen most
guys don't have the balls to go on any
show where people disagree so I have
immense amount of respect for that what
I am saying is let me sort of
crystallize it this why deal I do not
believe for a second okay for a second
that you hate transgender people I don't
believe for a second that you are afraid
of them and all I ask is for leftists
like yourself to give that exact same
benefit without the Conservatives rather
than ascribing motive is that me give
you my analysis of what you say and
certainly that that would be fair that
works okay there of the day and often
times it is it if people are as fair as
you and open-minded as you've been we
don't have these conversations but we do
and we have them because some of the
assertions that I've made you I don't I
refuse you watch any if I could see
mutate I think some people on Fox News
they're exactly these days I was on Fox
News for four and a half years these
exactly these days four and a half years
I've never heard I've never heard anyone
on Fox News go on and say all black kids
are thugs black lives don't matter you
did you did you said if they can say all
black kids have hoodies if all black
kids a thug's I've never heard anyone
say that as a matter of fact the one I
did is Geraldo Rivera who is not very
smart and he's a liberal he's a liberal
he's our liberal and he's not very
bright no I literally just said it but
you kept interrupting me people who are
listening people who are listening no
let me say this for a second just so you
don't look foolish I said it as you were
speaking I said nobody except Geraldo
who's liberal
that's exactly what I said I have heard
I ever arguably they're getting they're
not news people they're getting hot
panties
so when you say I've never heard that on
that network that is that is patently
false and you know it I didn't know no
it's not it's not patently false II
again you're ascribing motive and this
is why these conversations happen to you
and you refuse to see the logic in it
you just made an assumption you just
described the motive I said the exact
words do my exact words were I've never
heard anyone say it except for Geraldo
Rivera there's not that bright and is a
liberal that's exactly what I said what
why are you going back to it I gave you
that one Geraldo said the hoodie thing
okay and he's a liberal is it he's a
long way from a liberal now and you know
it no no we don't know it I don't know
it is made of being too conservative on
his program nice guy you know doing no
no that's not what you said
what you said that's not what you said
you said you can hear these kinds of
things all the time on Fox News these
kinds of things were all young black
people are thugs they were all wearing
hoodies that's very different from
Geraldo Rivera one liberal with a
mustache said Trayvon was wearing a
hoodie those are very different forget
the people here you come on and said but
can I have an early no but you've made
the claim and you've made the claim for
example here's the thing if you go to a
college debate club mr. ugly if you say
I've heard plenty of Republicans say all
young black people are thugs all young
black people wearing hoodies you have to
rationalize that statement and Geraldo
Rivera doesn't count
let's just speak in some soundbite
platitude that Oprah would like how
about backing up your assertions you
made some very very serious exactly what
I think I said specifically we you met
you you you may be accepted oh I don't
care who it is that conversation was
happening at a time when we were all
talking about why it's like men are
finding themselves dead industry yeah
and the other surgeon the conservative
agenda has never made a certainly very
recently hasn't made an outreach unless
he doesn't vet in case you want the kind
of black people that agree with you you
want the kind of black people they had
the same perfect I seem to want the same
kind of black people as a Yale detective
let me be let's be let's be clear it
would be advantageous to have black
people who speak for you the other black
people respect yeah
so people people like that people like
larry elder colon Powell Clarence Thomas
Condoleezza Rice Ben Carson
shouldn't be respected see again you
take one example one example you gave I
gave you five examples ok let's take
away : home Ben Carson ben Carson Alan
West Alfonso Rachel larry elder what
salt is that cars
there's it's not you calling Republicans
not Caesar racist you can't be you can't
blame me for somebody not liking they're
missing no I blame I blame the arguing
tactics you use here in ascribing motive
for creating race and the people don't
buy it the people the people of the
market if you market a product and it is
moving is it your marketing is it your
message so you think so you think that
Lyndon Johnson you think that Lyndon
Johnson you think the New Deal you think
Detroit they've marketed those things
really effective to block you I think
every black person in destroyed would
know exactly what's been marketed to
them and it's destroyed Detroit and the
black community you could play these two
things you mrs. Lyndon Johnson you
mentioned uh you mention Lyndon Johnson
so rate society to to to specifically
say getting back to what I said before
you mention a bunch of people who would
not a be welcome in a lot of black
neighborhoods
Marleen feels comfortable in it
comfortable in it really
you don't think Herman Cain you don't
think Herman I mean Herman Cain for
crying out loud
oh you think Barack using Barack Obama
has more cred than Herman Cain you don't
think I'm in Cain as a black American in
Georgia black people like you can't tell
me what it is I can't be Bible that you
like because you speak on behalf of all
black people there are plenty of black
people who like everything there is a
reason that you traditionally only get
less than 10% you can't say that most
black people's fought that is in your
message that's not in my message that is
in the people you choose to carry water
you want you in essence saying is that
they're not they don't get it marketing
if you buy dog food and the dogs don't
eat your product and all your marketing
we're gonna have to go through this with
the oh crap button for the terrestrial
broadcast listen I completely disagree I
know you're a busy man I do hope that we
can discuss this again my point is I
defend your right to say it
I don't believe you're a trans Fobo hope
people hear this and I do hope mr. I do
say is genuinely genuinely beyond the
sensationalism of radio beyond us
debating on air the only thing that
you've done that I find alarming I have
no problem with you having a point of
view he's describing a motive to your
opposition I well you know what is in
that regard I am like most people on the
right okay but okay in this conversation
in this conversation you're the only one
who when they constantly ascribe a
motive is that fair in this conversation
only you didn't grab the motive to this
president or black people in general
here's the thing I'll say this land I've
never been I've been on Bill O'Reilly
I'm gonna say I'm not afraid to talk to
anybody buddy right I'll tell you this
if you if it is you want to conservative
move it to take root places you as I you
as as whatever I know that you have to
change either the marketing the message
or the product that's a fair statement
right I completely agree the marketing
the packaging sucks right so so if it is
that black people don't biologic and
pole people they do not have a very high
approval in the Colin Powell did
certainly and I think he could have a
gentleman but he doesn't seem to be a
bad you know clown he doesn't seem to
have that opinion it okay but when you
tell me about
Herman Cain when he said about Larry
elderly about okay but we have to go
here in a second we're gonna lose the
time is it fair to say you just talked
about I'm talking about you and I would
it be fair to say that in this
conversation between DL Hughley and
steven crowder you were the only one to
ascribe a motive to me by saying i was
doing it is it is unfair to say that
it's fair to say this because I'm not
gonna what I'm going to do is tell you
from office
you have you like for instance you
brought up the picture than of Nazi
Germany I in terms of X Bob I've given
you an example that's what I did but I
wouldn't say ascribe a motive to you
I've scrapped the motives of people that
did seem to be of European okay but you
didn't say I was being disingenuous
you said I was disingenuous and I'm just
saying I'm not well in that particular I
thought you were I think that you fitted
me you said to me you never inner that
you want if I support those and you
never heard except for what the
exception may is the very thing that I
had so that to me seemed to be
disingenuous if you were saying that he
had never happened people that made me
feel like I was lying or advocating or
telling you something that what sugar
yeah well I stay I stand by what I said
because he made some pretty outlandish
claims and I was saying I've not heard
those I still haven't heard those that's
not what you claimed again that's not
what you claimed you claimed all
Republicans although as a liberal as a
Democrat card-carrying liberal can't
voted Obama twice my point is I said
again you said they say all young black
people are thugs no yes you did yes you
did this is a problem of the Internet as
people can literally remind this twenty
minutes and you're exactly what you said
yes people make these asserts of what
they do is they go hey uh you know
there's a high crime area like they will
you know they wear hoodies and people
are scared and that's the argument I
make so if it came out a little
different than that okay that's give me
a lawyers I think we can both agree we
don't need more lawyers in the middle of
these conversations people say when they
hang up on the work I believe sincerely
in what I'm saying I believe
I have an obligation to see there's no
reason why I can go on in each other cuz
there's a reason I can do
there's a reason you'll see a lot of I
could whether it be Marla bilham I don't
need it and I'll be the exact same
person there's a reason I could defend
Don Imus or there's a reason I can I can
I can defend my right to say because I'm
exactly why I'm solution thought in my
heart the things I say are true I
believe in my heart there is it
specifically either is apathetic sort
towards here's what I'll say the reason
that your movement is not registering
but people that are like me he's not
because of me it's not because of me
it's not because of I'm wilfully hateful
it's not because I am ignorant or don't
understand it is because it does not
seem to be welcoming today okay you're
you're mad it doesn't seem to be and
they made you pick to carry your water I
know no no no that's not fair
I've not picked any of those people to
carry my water I was at Fox News for
four and a half years and I left listen
we have to we have to go we've missed
breaks I've been horribly unprofessional
deal I really appreciate you coming on
you're right you are consistent even
though I think you're wrong I do
appreciate that you're willing to go in
any form
I do appreciate you taking the time and
yes I still think you're wrong but mr.
googley thank you so much we'll be back
louder with Crowder stay tuned sorry we
went over if you like this video you
want to subscribe you just didn't know
it yet but I just let you know you click
my face boom it's done or you can watch
one of these videos next to me if you're
not quite sure yet if you're not quite
sure yet your video curious which means
that you're just selfish